Kyle Lowry have that huge
perhaps mr. have a playoff game 30.7
Reeboks met by lopez on a switch they
double up like home cooking and if
you're Fred vanvleet who has struggled
and defensively you would have your guys
to limit Yanis but considering the Bucs
depth is there anywhere you'd like to
see improvement on that end
well Middleton's here it is the saved on
a pass that is off the mark and then
it's broken up to steal by van fleet and
puts it home shot clock to five
fires for three Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
understand why
these gentlemen shot clock to five
and sleep with his staff
[Applause]
while we step it back on their addiction
fighters it out bat bleep yes
[Applause]
shot five and three
I'm catching [ __ ] here and who does not
realize the offensive ability of Kawhi
Leonard here is a terrific defender
here's VanFleet for picking up on that
last play but obviously alright what is
on the floor here is their Cleveland
there you go
no hesitation go ahead here comes Lowrey
out of a pack yes
you make cicadas achieving over Chris
Powell van fleet support 3 again
playing by Ibaka but the ditch in
nineteen points but still you want him
to make the best of those double tees
[Music]
[Applause]
for free again
is working toward his workers life in
our Kauai had to get loose he has two
good news
with the two points here by kawaii fines
vanvleet for the long three three
Middleton cold on the foul at this sad
carefree
George Hill will go to the line is he
not talking about rich wizard help on
defense you know this man has been hot
since the birth of his son toosha for
tonight at the line let it off the
double fire
we've got a we've got to adjust and move
our feet and keep our hands off more but
with 12 minutes to go and a trip to the
finals on the line how do you maintain
the momentum that you've gained here
flexo show him why he was first team on
defense
the last three ballgames look at this
side and step through here